فيما يجري ميدانيا اليوم في السودان ينضم
الينا من بيروت العميد الياس حنا الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي عميد الياس حنا ما
تفسير ضراوه المعارك اليوم بشكل كبير
المراسلون يقولون في السودان ان هذه اعنف
المعارك منذ بدايه الاشتباكات والمواجهات
العسكريه
هذا يعني ان سقوط الهدنه
والفريقان يستفيدان من وقف النار يعني من
حقق شيء لتحسين وضعه لتثبيته ومن فشل في
مكان اخر لتحسين الوضع يعني اليوم نتحدث
عن تراجع في الاماكن الاساسيه يعني القصر
الجمهوري القياده العامه وحتى حول المطار
هذا الامر يدل على عده امور واحد ممكن ان
يكون هناك
احترام للهدنه وهذا الامر لم يثبت او الشق
الاخر هو فعلا سيطره الجيش على هذه
المناطق
والمعارك تدور في جنوب السودان كما اتى في
الخارطه التفاعليه المنطقه بين النيل
الازرق والنيل الابيض وفي ثلاث احياء مهمه
وهناك تدور المعارك والهدف دائما هو قطع
الامدادات عن شمال الخرطوم وبالتالي
محاوله تنظيف هذه المنطقه عاده ال سي في
الحروب المدن وفي حروب الشوارع
الهدف او كل شخص يظهر يؤخذ على انه عدو
حتى اثبات العكس وهذا امر يستلزم وقت في
مساحه على مساحه كبيره وبالتالي يستلزم
عديد كبير معين ونحن لا نزال في بدايه هذا
عمليه التنظيف العميد الياس
المعلومات شحيحه من الميدان باعتبار لا
نعرف
طبيعه المعارك وكيف تدور لكن المعلن الان
ان طرف قال بانه يريد هدنه لمده ثلاثه
ايام الجيش يرفض الدخول في هدنه وسمى هذه
العمليه عمليه المسح لما سماها البؤر بؤر
التمرد وهو ما نشاهده الان من ارتفاع
اعمده الدخان في عدد من الاحياء هل هناك
تفسير لاقدام الجيش على هذه الخطوه هل يرى
انه في وضع افضل يسمح له
بتحديدا بمسح هذه المناطق وتنظيفها كما
يقول
عبد السلام
موازين القوى هي لصالح الجيش والجيش هو
عمليه ماسسه هو مؤسسات لديها قواعد لديها
سكنات لديها رابط اساسي بين بعضها البعض
ولديها اللوجستيه الكافيه وذلك بعكس الدعم
السريع حيث قاعدته الاساسيه هي ليست في
الخرطوم هي في غرب البلاد في اقليم
الدارفور هذا الامر يدل ان الدعم قد يعاني
من صعوبات ميدانيه وصعوبات لوجستيه ويعتبر
الجيش ان هذه الفرصه هي مناسبه للحسم في
هذه المنطقه والانتقال الى اماكن اخرى هذا
بالاضافه الى ان الجيش سرعه الحسم تمنع
التدخل الخارجي وحسب مجله او جريده
وحتى سي ان ان هناك بدا تدخل معينا من
خارج البلاد ياتي من الجهه الليبيه
لدعم الدعم السريع فاذا انت امام مرحله
سباق مع الوقت لمن يسيطر على هذه الاماكن
اريد ان انوه الى هذا الخبر العاجل على
شاشتنا الان
مراسل الجزيره يقول ان القوى الموقعه على
الاتفاق او قوى سياسيه تتحدث عن قبول
الجيش والدعم السريع بوقف القتال خلال
العيد
طيب
العميد الياس يعني كما ذكر
عبد السلام يعني المعلومات شحيحه من
الميدان
ولكن نعلم مثلا ان قوات الجيش استقدمت
تعزيزات بالامس الى الخرطوم واليوم تتحدث
عن تمشيط بري في العاصمه ما دلالات كل ذلك
وما معانيه
التمشيط يعني انه تم الاستيلاء على هذه
المنطقه ولكن عندما يتم النصر او هزيمه
الفريق الاخر هناك ما يسمى بالامن
العملاني هذا الامن العماني يتطرب يتطلب
تمشيطا تطهيرا والقبض على ما تبقى ومنعه
وحصر القوات المتوفره في هذه المنطقه
وبالتالي الاعلان السيطره عليها بشكل كامل
نحن نعرف تماما ال سي ان هذه المنطقه او
الخرطوم او هذا المثلث المهم جدا فيه
مراكز الصقل الاساسيه القياده العامه
القصر الجمهوري المطار وبالتالي في ام
درمان الاذاعه وهناك كانت تدور كل هذه
المعارك يبدو ان الكفه وحسب المؤشرات
الميدانيه شحن معلومات امر اساسي يبدو ان
من خلال المؤشرات الميدانيه ان الجيش لديه
اليد العليا حتى الان يبقى ماذا سيفعل
الدعم السريع هل سياتي بقوات من الخارج
يبدو ان البارحه في منطقه المويلح تم
استخدام الطيران لضرب اعداد قادمه للدعم
السريع باتجاه ام درمان او باتجاه العاصمه
شكرا جزيلا لك العميد الياس حنا الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي ضيفنا من بيروت